There are so many new beauty products
being released all the time,
so we gathered some of the most hyped
from the last month to test for ourselves.
I've been dying to try
out this Freck Cheekslime,
mainly because of the name,
and I've been obsessed with all kinds
of liquid blushes lately.
I'll admit I went in too hot.
I applied way too much too fast,
and I think the sponge
wasn't the best way to apply this.
She was giving clown,
so we did a take two.
I used less, and I went in with a brush,
and it worked out so much better.
This stuff dries down super quickly,
so I recommend doing one cheek at a time,
but the color payoff is amazing.
I don't think I like it
very much as a lip tint.
It was kind of patchy
and powdery feeling on the lips.
But as a blush, I love it.
This orange shade is so fun.
I've seen these Glisten
split cake liners before,
but I've never tried them out.
They released this limited-edition
rainbow Pride Liner,
and 100% of the profits are going
to LGBTQIA+ charities,
which is incredible.
This was kind of
intimidating to use at first.
I'm not great at, like,
cool eyeliner looks,
but this did make me want
to experiment a little.
The colors are so, so pigmented.
The one that did give me
a little bit of trouble
was the yellow.
I think I applied it with too much water,
and it got a little patchy,
but I think I fixed it.
And the liners dry down super quickly.
I'm not going to make a habit
of featuring limited-edition stuff,
but this one felt too
special to not include.
Also, this is probably
going to last me forever,
so I feel like it's totally worth it.
I saw a TikTok of someone trying out
this Charlotte Tilbury liner,
and it made their eyes look
so gorgeous and sparkly,
so I needed to try it.
The black side worked fine,
but this metallic gold side
is what I'm obsessed with.
It went on my waterline super smoothly,
which hasn't really been my experience
with other pencil liners.
I have an unusually wet waterline,
so no eyeliner ever sticks to it,
but this one went on so easily.
I feel like I can definitely
see a bit of difference in the eye
with the gold liner versus without it.
It really does reflect the light
right onto your eye,
so you have, like, these sparkly,
beautiful Disney princess eyes.
I think this is a new favorite for me.
Skin tints are still going
strong in beauty right now.
This one is from Huda
Beauty's new GloWish line.
I thought that I wouldn't like this,
but the second I blended
it in, I was obsessed.
This gives your skin the most amazing glow
and looks like you have
no foundation on at all.
The glow isn't the most
natural-looking sheen,
but I still think it looked amazing.
This is low coverage.
It didn't cover up any of
my dark spots super well,
but it did a good job of
evening out my skin tone.
I do think this is pretty
overpriced, though.
$37 for a skin tint?
That just feels wrong.
Phytosurgence is a new brand for me.
I recently saw this
blush balm on Instagram,
and it's supposed to be like
skin care and makeup in one.
It has meadowfoam seed oil in it,
which is supposed to
be super moisturizing,
and it also has kokum butter,
which will soften the skin
without clogging your pores.
I was nervous about putting
this on over my foundation,
but it actually applied nicely.
The texture is more moussey than balmy,
which is interesting.
It's super pigmented,
so I didn't have to use too much.
I think I messed up
by going over the blush with a sponge,
because I removed a
small patch of foundation
when I did that.
I think using a brush
and just leaving it alone
is probably the best
way to work with this,
but I still really, really like it.
And this does dry down to
a soft, powdery finish.